[MUSIC PLAYING]
RAUL LEON: Well,
thank you, Dominic.
Thanks for the opportunity
to be here at Google.
to be able to share
some space and time with
you at this lunchtime.
I'm very excited
to be able to share
a little bit about my
experience and expertise
with chief diversity officers.
And I'm really happy to
see that you're taking time
to really learn about a topic
that I'm very passionate about
and I think is very pertinent
for the work of colleges,
universities, and
organizations today.
To begin, I'd like to tell
you a little bit about what
I envision this
session could be or how
we are going to spend the time.
So I would like to share
a little bit of insight
about my academic
journey, because I
think it will explain why
I'm interested in the topic.
I would like to situate
the work of the CDO
to think about how they
are change agents in higher
education.
I would like to share
my understanding
about the work of the CDO.
And also, I will be more than
happy to welcome questions
in a lively discussion,
stemming from some of the facts
or some of the information
I'm going to present to you.
My interest in the topic stems
from my time in grad school.
As you might think
about grad school
or think about what
do you do in college,
it's a time in which you
have to find something
that you're passionate about.
In this case, I was pursuing
my master's and doctorate
at the University of
Wisconsin, Madison.
And I was there roughly
from 2005 to 2010.
And when I had the task to find
a topic for my dissertation,
I had to figure out,
what topic will move me
into the next
stage of my career?
What topic will have me
interested for long enough,
but yet will allow me to
complete a dissertation, which
is this large document,
to be able to say,
I'm an expert in this
part of the field.
And at that time, I
had worked in places
such as international
student services.
I had worked in a study abroad.
I had worked with
communities that
foster a sense of engagement
for international students.
And I have also served
at pre-college programs.
So that was my background.
And that was sort of
my work experience
while I was in grad school.
So I was trying to find a
topic that sort of suited those
experiences and also was a good
choice for an academic pursuit,
such as a dissertation or
a journal in the future.
As I did that,
one of the aspects
that got me interested
in the topic
is that I had the opportunity
to sit in the committee.
Many of you probably
have done that,
in which you are tasked
to serve in a committee
and be able to do something for
the good of the institution.
In this case, the committee
was the Diversity Committee.
And this committee was
the wide campus committee,
meaning it called
for representatives
of all areas of the campus.
That would be faculty, students,
administrators, community
members.
And this was a
committee that was
tasked to sort of move the
diversity agenda forward
at the institution.
After being on the committee,
I believe, for two years,
I think in my third
year, I volunteered
to co-chair the committee,
because not only I
was an eager student to be
able to undertake this task,
but I also really had a
passion for the leadership that
had come into the institution.
What occurred is that in
2008, Dr. Damon Williams
was appointed as the first chief
diversity officer at University
of Wisconsin, Madison.
Maybe you recognize his
name, because he was just
recently recognized at
the bicentennial event
at the University of
Michigan, appointed
as the person that
gave the speech,
and also has written
extensively about CDOs.
So I was really happy
to have an expert
in the field in chief
diversity officers
and someone that was
starting as the first person,
and also co-chair in
the committee with.
At that time, you might
say, the topic finds you.
So I was interested in writing
about chief diversity officers.
Why?
Because I had an
extensive period in time
in which I was witnessing
how someone in that role
could move an
institution forward.
As I think about or give a brief
definition to set our context,
or just to set what a chief
diversity officer is--
as you think about
it in the context
of academic institutions, a CDO
would be a person or individual
that reports to the president of
the provost, has a direct line,
and also is a person that is
the highest diversity rank
administrator at
the institution.
When we think
about what CDOs do,
I think the timeline
of the talk does not
allow us to delve
into exactly how you
will define it,
describe it, and sort
of talk about the position.
But roughly, it's a person that
coordinates, leads, enhances,
and sometimes supervises
the formal diversity
capabilities of institutions.
And by "diversity capabilities,"
you can include people,
you can include programs,
you can include centers,
you can include resources.
So everything that deals
with diversity, this person
could come in and integrate,
coordinate, facilitate,
or bring together to be
able to maximize resources
when you are at an institution.
When you think about your
work as a doctoral student,
the biggest thing
that you have to do
is, what question do
you want to answer?
And how do you create
a good dissertation?
Meaning, you're
going to spend a lot
of time looking at this document
in front of your computer.
You're going to
spend a lot of time
looking at this document
and pages and editing.
So it has to be something
that catches your attention,
but also catches attentions
of others that are willing
or that will read this document.
So when I was thinking
about what to do,
I knew I wanted to know a
little bit more about the CDO.
And I also knew that I had
to add on what has already
been said about a CDO.
So those are the two things that
I was kind of keeping in mind.
And what was
happening at that time
is, when I met Dr.
Williams, he was actively
working in publishing
these two books.
You can see the "Strategic
Diversity Leadership
in Higher Education" and the
"Chief Diversity Officer."
So these two books were
projects that he was actively
working on while I was
also at the university.
So I not only had to
add to the literature,
but I was also sort of
competing to understand
what will I add to
what has been written
if you're going to
publish two books when
I finish my dissertation?
And the timeline sort of
worked that he was kind enough
to share some of
the first print-outs
or the drafts of
the books for me
to sort of enhance
my understanding.
But also, then I knew that I
needed to publish something
beyond that to further
my understanding,
given what he was going to come
up with the books, which today
are pretty much
the premier books
that people in
institutions have adopted
to understand the role of
CDOs in higher education
institutions.
So as I did that, I
figured that there
was one aspect of the literature
that he presented that I
was really interested on.
And that was the
organizational design
of the position of the CDO.
So, so far when I heard
people talk about the CDO,
they will mention
the CDO as a person,
the CDO as an individual.
But when you really
look at the literature,
the CDO could be
an office, a unit.
It could be a whole
team of people
that work under the
leadership of the CDO.
So I was interested, then,
in discovering questions that
dealt with the organization.
I was interested in
questions that deal with,
how do you actually
do your work?
So what strategies
do you utilize?
And then today, I will
connect that to, how
is that important for
the work that I do today
and for the work that you
might do today at Google?
So for the first
one, when you think
about organizational structure,
you might think about roles.
You can think about reporting
structures-- so who supervises?
What is your authority
over other people?
And I also think about
budget and resources.
So the role of the
position is everything
that allows you to do the
work that you do, given who
is around you and who you
have as a team or team
member or supervision.
One thing that was out
there that I benefited from
is that when people did
research about CDOs,
they had established that if
you looked at all the CDOs
that were present in
institutions of higher
education at that time,
you can roughly put them
in three models
and said, some CDOs
fall under the
collaborative CDO model.
Some CDOs fall under the
unit-based CDO model.
And some CDOs fall under the
portfolio divisional CDO model.
So I will explain in a little
bit what those models mean.
But roughly, if
you took everyone,
you could say, this
is the framework that
allows you to somewhat say, your
structure is similar to what
this model presents.
As we talked about
that, this was
the breakdown in which, in
2007, those CDOs were organized.
And you can see that roughly the
largest representation of CDOs
fell under the
collaborative CDO model.
Then we have the unit-based
CDO model second.
And then a very small proportion
of CDOs across the nation
were under the portfolio
divisional one.
And that was based on a survey
that Dr. Williams conducted
and reached about 110 CDOs and
about 70 interviews with people
that were currently
in that role.
So why is that important?
At that point, I knew
that I wanted to explore,
what strategies do people
in the position of CDO
pursue to develop, maximize,
and manage diversity?
But also, I wanted
to know, does being
in one of these configurations
actually influence
how you do your work?
Does it influence how
you adapt strategies?
Does it influence how you
execute your diversity work?
All right.
So when I was
doing my study, one
of the things that I
had to keep in mind
is that when you
compare something,
it is beneficial at times
when you actually compare
things that are similar.
So I could not pick
one CDO working
at a very small school
with 500 students
and then pick a CDO at a school
with 50,000 students in which
the configurations were
roughly super different
and would not allow
for a fair comparison.
So what I thought
about is that I
wanted to find commonalities
about a sample for me
to allow me to do
that comparison.
So I compare first
institutions that have adopted
a strategic diversity plan.
Then I wanted a CDO
that was reporting
to the president of provost,
because at that time,
people were trying to
figure out what a CDO was.
So there was different
configurations.
They would call someone with
authority and diversity a CDO.
But technically,
that person needed
to report to the
president or provost
when we're talking
about the role defined.
And also, I wanted to
find representation
of models that actually
represented the characteristics
of each of the configurations.
So add some fidelity
to, OK, I can
see you sort of check
all those things
that you are a good
representation of a CDO
model in this type.
And then I found three
CDOs at three institutions.
And I decided that I needed
to find the same institution,
meaning that I picked
research universities that
had the three different models.
So at the end of the day,
I had the three models
represented in
similar-sized institutions
with similar size and
population of students
with similar locations.
And the difference was
that they had those three
different models.
So I could also
do the comparison.
So as I think about
what happened in 2013,
you see a little
evolution of models sort
of moving towards
developing more portfolio
divisional models, but
also reducing the number
of collaborative CDOs.
And I will go into explaining,
what does that look like,
and why are they important
when you think about structure?
So this is what I found.
So when I went and
did my research,
graphically, this is what
the CDO configuration
at the collaborative
level would look like.
It's pretty flat.
You will have the CDO
person or the individual
representing that position.
And under that
person, that person
had three admin staff,
which could be someone that
helps them with
tasks in the office,
could be someone that
helps anywhere from payroll
to organizing events to
someone that does anything
that that person needs
to run the office itself.
At that time, the
fourth position
was being negotiated
and requested
for that person to be able to
fulfill the duties of the CDO.
So graphically, it
looked like that.
But when you think
about the things
that I've been
mentioning, as to what
does a CDO do, so in this
model, this model basically
values collaboration and
lateral coordination,
meaning this person
is actively trying
to build partnerships
horizontally and vertically
in the organization.
Two, they have various small
support staff, meaning they
probably have two or three
people that deal with f office.
But they are responsible
for diversity
in the entire institution.
Or at least, that is the
perception that you have
when you bring a chief diversity
officer to an institution.
Two-- or three, they
have no reporting units.
So no units across campus
reported to that person.
And then there was no one, which
was a diversity officer perhaps
in a program or a school, that
actually reported to them.
So when you think about your
organizational hierarchy
here in Google, so
this will be a person
that is a one-person office.
And you maybe have two
or three support staff.
And you do what you need
to do with your team.
And that is how things get done.
But there is very
little hierarchy
as to who reports to you to
be able to say, where are we
with this project?
It's more you try to convince
people that this is important.
Thinking about the unit-based
CDO-- the second model.
So in this model,
you see it's not
as flat as the unit-based CDO.
In this case, you have
now program associates,
which were not only
program administrators.
So the people in both
in this configuration
also provided expertise to be
able to carry out diversity
work, having expertise in
the field, in the topics,
and being able to work
with the CDO directly,
beyond just supporting
administrative tasks.
Also, at the time in which
I was exploring this,
the institution where
I was exploring this
were thinking about moving
a couple units on campus
under the supervision
of this role.
And as you might imagine,
some of the characteristics
are still the same.
But what changes from model
to model is, in this one,
you actually start supervising
other folks that deal
with diversity across campus.
You actually have a
broader span of priorities,
because now you have your
program associates sort of
to [INAUDIBLE] specific areas.
And one of the areas could
be faculty recruitment.
Another area could be
diversity training.
student success initiatives.
So now you have people
appointed to specific areas
that might be associated
with what you do.
And in this case, when you
compare a one-person office
to a person that has
program associates,
in this configuration,
you're more
likely to be involved with
the day-to-day implementation
of the tasks of activities
that take place across campus.
Why?
Simply, you have
three or four people
that are actually
actively working
with those versus being
a one-person office
that you might need to
deal with everything
just in the little
time that you have.
And then the third
model that I found
is the portfolio divisional CDO.
So graphically, it's apparent
that the structure is not flat.
It's apparent that there's a
lot more program associates.
It's apparent that there is
assistant to those associates.
There's also admin support.
And there is also 1, 2,
3, 4, 5, 6 reporting units
to this person.
So in this configuration,
all these units
with the staff that
they have and the admin
staff that they have, they don't
only do their work in a silo.
But they also report
to the CDO, meaning
the CDO establishes
the strategic plan
for all these units
and for the people that
report to this person.
So roughly, those three
models-- that's how they vary.
And when you looked
at the CDO portfolio
divisional configuration,
you can see that now you
have administrative staff.
You have program associates.
You can have people deal
with technical or marketing
or other aspects of
the work that you do.
You have reporting units.
You supervise other diversity
officers in the institution.
But you still value
collaboration.
You still value being able
to get a lot of aspects
of diversity work done.
But one thing that
occurs is that this model
was very uncommon across
colleges and universities.
And you can have
your hints as to why
it might have been uncommon.
Well, it might have
been expensive to run
an office with that many units
or people supporting the CDO.
And also, moving resources
under a CDO and saying,
you do the diversity work with
all these people under you,
might not have been the first
thing that people wanted
to do when creating a model.
They might have
appointed one person
first as a CDO
collaborative officer,
rather than establishing
an entire division
from the get-go.
So what did I find?
Because I wanted to find if
being one of those models
influenced what you
were able to do.
So what strategies did
CDOs in this position
utilize to carry out work?
Well, when I looked at what
had been written about it,
I could see that CDOs broadly
focus in several areas
that deal with diversity.
One of those areas was
educational strategies.
So they were there
to educate the campus
about the value of diversity.
They focus on
communication strategies,
which was communicate diversity
into the mission, vision,
and goals with the
entire institution.
They focused on entrepreneurial
strategies, which is basically
raising money or finances
devoted to the work
that you do pertaining
to diversity.
They engage with
symbolic strategies,
which is, how do you influence
the campus culture in relation
to messages that
pertain to diversity?
They engage with
accountability strategies,
where it's establishing
indicators about how
you assess diversity progress.
And also, they engage
with research strategies,
meaning they did
research to figure out,
what does diversity
look like, or what's
the interpretation of
diversity on their campus?
So this is what had been
written about CDOs when
I got to the point in which
I was doing my own research.
And when I did my
research, I was
able to figure out that they
also do two additional things.
One is, they engage
with diversity research,
meaning they actively
collaborate with faculty
and other people interested
in research in topics that
are associated with diversity.
And also, they directly
sometimes focus
on recruitment strategies
for faculty and students--
so building
pipelines or students
building pipelines or faculty
to come into the institution.
So when someone says, what
do diversity officers do?
These are the categories
that you could be like,
they focus on these seven
sort of types of strategies
to carry out their work.
But I wanted to move it a
step farther to figure out,
what does that actually mean?
What do you actually
do day-to-day?
When you say you educate
the campus, what do you do?
OK.
So my goal was to sort
of create a chart that
will allow me to capture
the day-to-day activities
that these CDOs were doing.
And remember that
when I mention CDOs,
I am mentioning the staff of
the CDO, the office of the CDO--
so the whole structure
that carries the work
that the CDO represents.
So when we look at the
location of the strategies,
when I looked at
the three positions
that I was interviewing
or that I did research
on at the three
different institutions,
you can see one thing.
Well, roughly, they were
doing similar stuff.
It looks like all of them
were doing similar efforts
in educating the campus.
So it seemed that educating
the campus about the role
of the CDO was pertinent.
And it made sense.
Why?
Because the positions were new.
They were just established
across many campuses.
So not many campuses
have actually
seen a position like that.
So they were asking, well,
what does this position do?
Or what is it supposed to do?
So it makes sense that all
of them began by doing that.
Then we moved into
communication strategies.
You see things like,
for instance, CDOs
spend time to develop a
website for their offices.
They spend time to be
present at public events.
They spend time soliciting
input from campus
to be able to draft
communications.
And once again,
roughly, it appears
that the three configurations
were doing the same tasks.
But as we move through
the configurations
and to the type of
strategies that they have,
then I found out that
some of the differences
started to emerge as to how
much these roles sort of had
accomplished while they have
focused on diversity work.
And you can imagine that
at the time in which I
was interviewing the people in
these positions and the people
that reported to the
CDOs, they had roughly
been on the position
the same amount of time.
And they had or
operated in institutions
that were of the same size.
So for me, I was
curious as to, well,
what is different among
what you chose to do?
And this is where I started
seeing those differences.
For instance, in this end, I saw
that accountability strategies
to be able to figure out if
the campus is making progress
towards diversity goals--
it started to be
a little bit more
of a priority for the portfolio
CDO and the unit-based CDO.
And as I moved through
more strategies,
like research strategies, as
I moved through other aspects,
I think you can see now
that the differences were
pretty apparent.
Like, the folks in the
collaborative model
or the folks in the
smaller more flat model
were not devoting
any time to fulfill
any other responsibilities of
the other type of strategies.
And why was this important?
Well, I then figured
out that one, well,
they were not moving
the diversity agenda
in those areas.
I understood that often
it dealt with if you
have one person doing
this type of work,
it's unlikely you will
focus on those priorities.
But I also start to discover
that the depth in which they
were moving these agendas
forward varied greatly.
So even when we had
them all check education
on the strategies and they all
were, for instance, sending
a message to campus, the
depth of that message, who
was in charge of the message,
how often the message was
repeated, it just
varied greatly, also
because of the structure.
So how is this relevant at
all for the work that I do
or for the work
that you might do,
knowing that, for instance,
Google has a chief diversity
officer, that chief
diversity officers actually
emerge in the business sector?
So in higher education, they
might be a newer position,
but sort of copied from
the business sector
to be able to move
diversity forward.
So when one thinks
about the CDO,
one criticism that you might
get is that when you hire a CDO,
this person arrives to
campus, and then guess what?
Diversity becomes a
priority once they're hired.
Well, that is
definitely not the case.
That is just--
I wish it was.
But when you hire this
person or once you
have hired a unit,
a division, people
will assume that everything
related to diversity
now is awesome, or it
works, or it will now pave
the way for future generations.
And I think one part that
we actually do not look at
is that we fail to consider, how
do you envision-- once you hire
this person, how are
they going to spend
their time at the institution?
So if you hire someone
as a CDO at Google,
what do you envision them to do?
Do you expect them
to sort of take
part in community leaderships?
Do you expect them to travel
around the office and Google
and communicate a message?
Do you expect them to sort of
focus on affirmative action
and compliance?
Do you want them
to produce reports?
So figuring out what priorities
have been established
for that person is something
that, it's important, but also
is, how are you going to support
that person as an institution
once they are
appointed in that role?
So when you think about other
divisions in the company--
like, most of your
units might have
a budget, might have
people in different roles,
might have a staff, they
have a reporting structure,
they have a buy-in
from the leadership.
And in this case, what we ask
is, when you appoint a CDO,
does this person have the same
buy-in as other executive level
people in the firm?
Because they have the C title.
They're an executive officer.
They report directly
to the provost.
But do they have that same
budget or similar budget
than other units
or similar access
or similar support or
people or reporting units?
Well, this is where the
disparities start to emerge.
So how is these work related
to the work that I do?
And I'm a faculty member.
So today, if you know anything
about faculty members,
you might be like, what
do you do on campus?
Well, you often find
us or see us teaching.
You see us or read or know that
we are often reading and doing
research.
And that's why we are
looking at our laptops a lot.
And then also, one part
that is not as visible
is that we take part into
service, meaning we devote time
to be in committees that
deal something with service
in the institution or
our peers or our programs
or our students.
So roughly, this is how faculty
or professor life sort of
is divided.
But as you think
about professor life
across the spectrum
of institutions,
it might look very different.
In some institutions,
research might take
the biggest chunk of your time.
Teaching might not be as
big, or it might actually
be more important than research.
And service might actually
be considerably larger
than you expected, coming
into an institution.
So when you think about
a faculty member--
and in my case, I'm
going to describe
to you what do I do
for research, teaching,
and service that could benefit
from the presence of a CDO.
So I have been engaged with a
few things that, when listing,
I don't think these
things are that unusual.
So I do think faculty members do
engage with this type of work.
So on my campus, I have
published articles,
meaning that I have engaged
in producing a scholarship.
Two, I have pursued grants
for funding those research
projects.
Three, I have prepared
graduate students or my team
to be able to conduct research.
I have also taught courses
and organized workshops
on campus for a topic that
I might have an expertise.
I have also chaired
search committees
to be able to bring
new people to campus
and to be able to identify
diverse candidates.
I have also support
local community efforts
or initiatives through or link
through my research or teaching
interest.
I have mentored
junior faculty that
came into our
program or department
to be able to serve--
like, make sure
they are successful
when they move
into the next round
of their career.
I advise student
organizations on campus.
I have created
initiatives on campus
that are focused on
fostering student success.
And I have also
contribute to create
what we will call a
pipeline of students that
can come in in institutions.
And today I work at Eastern
Michigan University,
with a focus to come to Eastern.
So as you think about all
those responsibilities,
you might be able
to make connections
to the type of
activities that you do.
And the reason that
I make that point
is that, when I think
about the work of the CDO,
I can see the CDO
sort of engaging
in these type of activities
or these type of roles,
supporting my work.
So for instance, a
CDO can fund stuff.
A CDO can serve as a platform.
A CDO can offer leadership.
A CDO can offer
visibility in the spaces.
They can offer in
a strategic plan.
They can be a partner.
They can align resources.
They can be a network
or part of a network.
And most important, they can
drive sustainable change.
But if I asked you to sort
of reflect in these aspects,
I think you might be able
to identify folks here
in your organization that are
tasked with these priorities
or with these roles.
So when I move it
back to connecting
how does this impact my
work as a faculty member,
I think about this.
A CDO could offer funding
for us to offer workshops
for the campus to
learn about a topic.
A CDO could be a platform to
be able to share publications
of a scholarship
of faculty members
to be able to engage the
campus in conversations
pertinent to a new area
or topic of research.
A CDO could offer
leadership to be
able to understand, how do
we foster student success not
only from the top
administrators,
but also from the units that
are engaged with this work?
A CDO could advocate for
visibility in spaces--
for instance, finding a
place in which a student orgs
can come, convene, and do the
work that they want to do.
A CDO could remind
other administrators
that a pipeline of students or
crafting a path for students
that are underrepresented should
be part of the strategic plan.
A CDO could be a partner, not
only with funding, but also
with the visibility, with
the campus community,
or with a local community
when you do a project.
Also, a CDO could
align resources.
If you have a new
research project,
there could be someone
in the office of the CDO
that offers a start-up
funding to conduct research.
And sometimes that
start-up funding
could be $500 to be able
to pay for transcriptions
of your interviews.
The CDO could also be the person
in which a network of faculty,
staff, students that are
passionate about this work
revolve around this
person, meaning
that it could be a
place where we train
and mentor junior faculty
to be able to understand
their responsibility with
respect to diversity.
And also, a CDO
could be someone that
fosters sustainable change.
Why?
Because often that person
could be part of what?
Search committees.
When you're bringing someone
new to the organization,
that is the biggest task
that we have in front of us.
Who we bring literally
means that they
will shape and continue to
shape how our organization moves
forward.
So thinking about the CDO and
thinking about what they do,
I find a lot of correlations
with what you do daily
around your work on campus.
I am very pleased, for instance,
that you have convened here
over the lunchtime
to be able to access
a workshop or a professional
development opportunity.
And today, sort of thinking
about Hispanic Heritage Month
just passed and being a person
that represents that heritage,
I'm really happy that
a focus or support has
been given to
bringing speakers that
might be able to talk about
a research in relation
to a topic as
important as diversity.
So with that, I wanted to
leave some space for you
to ask questions and engage
in a lively discussion of how
do you think this role connects
with some of the things
that you're doing here at
Google or some of the things
that you are engaging in
your daily activities.
And I'm going to leave
this slide up sort
of just to guide us in
the potential aspects
that I have identified as,
I saw connections of CDOs
actively working with this.
But most valuable,
I saw connections
of actively people like
you in the institutions
doing the work, because,
as I mentioned it,
once we hire a CDO,
diversity doesn't
become a priority next day.
It's when you, as an individual,
engage with that type of work.
And having a CDO could be
beneficial to offer you
a platform for that.
So thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Well, I can
start out with a question.
Thank you, again, so
much for taking time out
of your day to be here.
So in your research,
I'm curious to know
if there was a singular or
maybe a few of these categories
that maybe fell short that
had impacted most negatively
maybe the experience of
these units under a CDO
or then trickled down
to impacting negatively
the student body experience
at those particular campuses?
RAUL LEON: I think your question
is precise and is valuable.
Why?
Because when you think
about each of the campuses,
each of those campuses
had a history.
Each of those campuses
were deal with issues
that were pertinent to
that campus at that time.
So for some campuses,
the symbolic aspect
of appointing a CDO
was very relevant.
For other campuses to
have, for instance, worked
about enhances the
number of women
as a faculty member
in a discipline
was really important.
So it was really context-based.
So for those campuses,
one of the things
that was important
for them, it was
the presence of the CDO,
the visibility of the CDO,
but they also were
trying to grasp the,
how do we move forward, knowing
that this position might not
have everything that it needs
to do the work that they need--
so recognizing that,
yes, appointing a person
to do this work was
important, but how
do we move it to the next
level and make sure they have
the structure, the role, the
budget, the support staff
to make diversity priority?
So it depend.
And it varied from
campus to campus.
But it also highlighted aspects
for all those different venues.
What I will tell you is that
when we think about diversity
work, we should not identify
just one aspect and say,
this is what will
make diversity work.
It's sort of like all these
wheels have to move forward
in the same direction.
Otherwise, there will
always be something
important or important
to someone or to a unit
or to a group that we risk
leaving out if we just decide
to focus on certain aspects.
AUDIENCE: Kind of
piggybacking off of that,
a thought that was kind
of running through my mind
is, how does a CDO
potentially lift up or amplify
the voices of the most
underrepresented individuals?
And what I specifically
am speaking to
is intersections of identities.
And so you were just
speaking to running
the risk of
potentially leaving out
some of those highly
specific groups.
I guess I'm just curious,
how do you even begin
to amplify groups like that?
How do you begin to
learn about them?
How do you begin to bring
them into the organization
when they themselves, from
a physical standpoint,
might only be one person?
RAUL LEON: Yeah, absolutely.
I think your question
is very real,
meaning I think
that is a question
that many folks or individuals
or groups on campuses
or at organizations
might have today.
And I think the best way for me
to answer that question might
be to give you some examples.
So for instance, if I think
about the type of workshops
that are run on a campus, being
able to incentivize people
and support people
to explore topics
that deal within a
specific group of students
or faculty or staff
or individuals
might be a way in which you find
now a space for those people
to be able to be
present on campus.
The other part is that when
you think about visibility
of spaces, it could be
anywhere from designating
a space in which you have
allies and advocates to be
able to designate
months or dates
or celebrations that
deal with recognizing
the valuable contributions
of people that
are identified with groups
on campus that are today
underrepresented.
When you talk
about publications,
you could put a call,
as a CDO, supporting
areas of the literature that
they are underrepresented
and could say,
we're specifically
looking for scholars on campus
that focus on A, B, or C areas
that, you know what,
there are not journals
that really pushing that today.
But you give them a venue to
maybe jump-start a journal
to start your own field.
And you see that
in the literature.
Today, you see many journals
that before didn't existed.
I publish diversity work.
And if you think
about 50 years ago,
there might not be a venue that
truly valued work on diversity.
Today, you have the "Journal of
Diversity in Higher Education."
You have other journals
that are specifically
seek out to scholars that
are interested in that type
of work.
Another way is network.
You can create affinity groups.
So as a CDO, you can really
connect people inside
of your institution that might
not see each other every day.
As a faculty member, I will
tell you that we are in silos.
We have a lot of
control about what
we do with our class, with
our research, with our time.
And sometimes when you
even ask technology-- like,
the ability to
teach online or be
able to teach
through computers--
you're not even
connecting to the folks
that work in your office.
So you might be a
little more distanced.
So where are those
opportunities for me
to run into someone
that, in this case,
represents my same
identity on campus?
I think you can think about
my responsibility of finding
those folks.
But also, what if the CDO
could have an affinity group
or support an affinity group
or provide a space or even just
add to the language in
which those type of groups
are valuable on campus and
give them a goal and a purpose?
So there's different
ways in which
I will say a CDO
could contribute
to connecting, giving
voices, providing
places for discussion.
But also, how do you
integrate those things
to the bigger conversation?
When we think about
a strategic planning,
is there anything in
the strategic plan
that speaks to those needs,
that speaks to those wants,
that speaks to those
identity groups?
If there is not,
then where do we
see it reflected in the
day-to-day activities
that people on campus do that?
And I think that's how
they can leverage and be
an advocate for those groups.
AUDIENCE: So there's
a lot for a CDO to do.
One thing at Google we've
worked really hard on
is not just
increasing diversity,
but once people are
here, that everyone
feels they can be
successful and included.
Have you found in your
research that there's
specific things a CDO, or
just groups in general,
that has the biggest impact
on that aspect of encouraging
inclusion throughout
the environment?
RAUL LEON: Yep.
So you hit the nail right on the
head, meaning a lot of people
talk about diversity and
inclusion and use the analogy,
invite people to the dance but
then actually dance with them.
And one of the
analogies is that,
what makes people feel
valuable in your organization?
So I'll assure you that
hiring a CDO does not
make you feel valuable if you
have never contact that person,
you have no idea
what a CDO does.
And I'm reflecting as
putting on my student hat.
If I was a student,
it's unlikely I even
know the name of the president,
the provost, or the faculty
senate, or anyone that
deals with administration
in your institution.
You're likely to know
maybe your advisor.
But you are more
likely to know, who?
Leaders in other
student orgs, people
that live in your floor,
people that actually
are connected to
the type of programs
that are offered to you.
So my idea or my
research, what it tells me
is that, how do we trickle down
the actions and initiatives
that the CDO does
to parts of campus
that people might see
them as removed or silos?
So if you're a student living
in residential halls, as a CDO,
how could you
promote those spaces
to be spaces in which you
have a sense of belonging?
So for instance, you
could have a meeting,
or you could have a space
in which you actively
provide training to
resident advisors
to gain cultural competency.
As a CDO, you could provide
funds for the community,
for instance, to
purchase a book that you
do a campus reading to really
bring that community together
over one topic.
And all those examples,
you might be like, well,
anyone can do that.
But also, if no
one is doing that,
someone with that vision, those
ideas, and that leadership
could jump-start that in
different pockets of campus.
And I think that resonates
with the previous question,
is that there are going
to be a lot of things
that the CDO could do.
Now, should they do
all those things?
Well, in an ideal world, yes.
Can they do all those things?
Well, time has limited
number of hours.
You probably will find not every
position looks like a portfolio
divisional CDO.
Resources are not as available
in many of the institutions.
But a CDO could be a person that
has the expertise and knowledge
to know where can I get the
most return for my buck,
meaning strategically leading
what we can accomplish,
knowing who we are-- so
maximizing who you are.
And I think that's
part of the leadership.
You have leaders that they
are brought to institutions
to be able to move
things forward,
because they know how
to move things forward.
So when you bring someone with
an expertise in diversity, what
you're expecting is,
you hire a person
that is knowledgeable
about all these aspects
to be able to move the
institution forward,
even if it begins by purchasing
a book or organizing a talk.
AUDIENCE: So in your experiences
and in your research,
how have you found is a great
way to measure the impact?
So for context, at Google, we're
in a lot of employee resource
groups.
And sometimes it's hard
to quantify impact.
We use attendance numbers
and things like that.
But what has been successful,
in your experience?
RAUL LEON: Really good question.
When you think about the
responsibilities of the CDO,
one of those was
accountability, in which you're
able to measure,
well, how do we know
that we are moving forward
in this diversity scale
or in this diversity platform?
And you're right.
Most of the times, what we
do is we refer to numbers.
And we refer or really silo
diversity into representation.
And I think representation
is important.
Equity and being able to
have people that represent
society working for institutions
is extremely important.
But then it jumps
to the next part.
Besides just taking
attendance, how
would you measure that the
contributions or the training
or what you're implementing
is really, actually emerging
in your day-to-day activities?
And one part in which I can
see that is by another example.
So let's say that
you have training
that deals with cultural
competency and bias reduction.
One of the best places in
which you could see that
is when you see people
advocating and really
understanding the search
process to bring new candidates.
And you make decisions
like, hi, Nick, last year we
only brought 10 candidates.
What can we do to enhance
our pool this year?
Two, are we advertising
in the right places
to be able to recruit
the right candidates?
Three, maybe we should spend
some time thinking about,
where is our pipeline of
candidates coming through
to be able to get people that
will be interested in working
in Google in the future?
So when I think about where
do you see those measurements,
you see them in the process.
And that's why sustainability
is pretty important.
If you don't have procedures
in which you have also
now embedded diversity, then
you keep just doing responsive
or work that deals with crisis.
How do you actually create
process in which you now
embed what do you
know about diversity
and now it becomes a natural
aspect of the day-to-day things
that you do as a hiring
manager, as a supervisor,
or as a mentor?
Think about a new colleague
in your institution.
How do you teach them
the culture here when
they come to your office?
You might be like, well, I
don't know, they just learn.
Well, are there ways in
which they provide training?
Are there ways in which
they read about who we are?
Is there ways in which
they are socialized?
So I think having
those things and being
intentional about what is
provided is really critical,
because otherwise,
there is a fine line
between intentionality
and, well, we just do it
when someone tells us to do so.
And if it works, it's great.
If not, we just check the box.
And those are very
two different things--
the quality of interactions
versus the quantity
of things that you do.
Now, you can check all the
boxes for diversity training
that you have.
But when you do the evaluation,
how valuable has it been?
What do people
report saying, this
is how my day-to-day activities
or role or leadership
has changed.
So how do we ask different
questions versus, did you
complete diversity training?
AUDIENCE: I have
another question.
RAUL LEON: Absolutely.
AUDIENCE: Is there
one thing that,
in your experience with CDOs,
something that keeps them up
at night?
If you were to be voicing
maybe for a lot of CDOs,
do you think that there's
one topic or something that
might keep them up at night?
RAUL LEON: Keep
them up at night--
I think by having been in a
few campuses as a student,
as a staff, as a faculty,
and by reading the news,
I think a lot of the CDOs are
kept at night by knowing that,
for instance, a racial
incident may occur at any time
in our campuses, knowing that
a graffiti or knowing that
message in a bathroom, or
knowing one that name-calling
on a campus road might be
something that totally triggers
the we-are-in-crisis response.
And you're not prepared
to deal with that.
And I think that that
could move back work
that you've done for years.
It's something that probably
keeps you worried, because it's
sort of saying,
you know that you
have built a good foundation
with the institution when
you can respond to
these incidents in a way
that you truly know that is
not who the institution is,
but more important,
your students
know that, your faculty know
that, your staff knows that.
If those things happen and
your students are not unsure
as to whether you even
support that or your faculty
are not unsure as to
whether you have devoted
enough time to that, a CDO
probably will be worried about,
how do I now spend time assuring
or reassuring the campus
that we care about this?
Well, campus or people
are going to need
evidence, are going
to need examples,
are going to need that, what
can I see in which I can
see this work has been done?
If they don't see that, I think
that's an area in which they
will be worried.
And the other part is
that engaging people
beyond their staff.
So we can have two things.
You have a very small office.
So you need to
collaborate and try
to engage everyone around you to
move the diversity agenda, not
an ideal place.
But also, if you
have a large office,
how do you engage those people
that now feel that, well, you
have a diversity officer
and a staff and teams,
diversity is no longer
my responsibility.
So how do you do
the dance between--
actually, it only works when
you take it as a priority,
whether there's a CDO or
whether there's no CDO.
So I think those two
things are things
that all the campus that I talk
grapple with and sort of convey
and said, this is
happening today,
and it's totally causing--
not trouble, but just not moving
as fast as we would like to.
And I will say that the purpose
of this presentation or sharing
this with you is that I
wanted to create the ability
or foster a little bit
of curiosity as to,
how do you engage with
some of the activities that
were shown in the areas in
which you totally work today?
So if it's marketing,
if it's outreach,
if it's PR, if it's tours--
so I was really happy to see a
tour coming in the door today.
But I'm thinking,
OK, how do you create
a pipeline from those tours?
What do those tours take back
once they go back to the places
or communities they represent?
It's sort of like actively
thinking about, well,
I am responsible
for doing tours.
How do you move
it one more notch
to incorporate the
importance of diversity
when those tours are designed,
planned, implemented?
Who do they get to see
when they come here?
Who do they get to talk?
What do they get to talk about
once they reach these doors?
And I think being intentional
about our reflection
is powerful.
And I think that's what
comes with leadership.
And that's what comes
with experience.
And I think as you
move up, you realize
and start seeing spaces
in your organization
that you had a blind
side for before.
You might be like, I
never considered this
as in this rank.
But when you move
as a supervisor,
well, you should be able
to see those things.
And now it's too
late to be like,
I never learned, so I'm just
going to go with what I know.
Well, this is the time in
which you build yourself
as a professional that
can truly build leadership
for those that come behind you.
AUDIENCE: Thank you
so much for coming in.
It was great to hear you speak.
So a round of applause again.
Thank you.
RAUL LEON: Thank you.
Thank you for having me.
[APPLAUSE]